my
the softer side of Germany's most
successful hard rockers for their mtv
unplugged gigs the Scorpion swapped
their electric guitars for acoustics and
that wasn't the only novelty the rock
dinosaurs were confronted with digo
solution I think it's change we had to
get used to was that MTV wanted us to
perform sitting down the emotion ganas
de musica afterburner that's I'm going I
mean it makes sense it's not about
making a show of it it's all about the
music well um de musique so in addition
to new numbers that meant playing their
classic hits the band says it was a
conscious decision to play in Greece a
country that's had a tough time
economically this year daga danke in a
fully disease politically tough times
it's easy to part with your friends when
you've got something to celebrate but
when your friends are at rock bottom
that's when you know who your real
friends are and that was one of the
reasons we said we're playing Greece
were going to weapons don't forget a hut
in
the band from Hanover started their trip
south in September
we're looking forward to happen see and
their fans in Greece could hardly wait
the spectacle took place in the leica
beta's amphitheater it was the first
open-air mtv unplugged concert and thus
corpse brought some musical friends
along for the event
you wanna start the fun I know I got
behind a spotter of humbugs revolverheld
right away he said I grew up with your
music and rock you like a hurricane it's
one of my favorite tracks I'd love to
sing and perform that song with you
together madea's inverter on the
Deutsche perform brother
former AHA frontman Morten Harket was
also on board
martin van it is morton was one of the
first people to sign up to the project
so was up and he chose wind of change
and i think it turned out to be a lovely
and unusual version of the song because
he has such an extraordinary voice to
the magic the Scorpions actually wanted
to go into retirement last year they've
trashed that idea now though
in the wind of change we're starting all
over again the scorpions unplugged marks
a new chapter in the band's history they
have gigs lined up in Eastern Europe
fans in Germany will get to see their
acoustic show at dates next year
[ __ ]